[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis Freitagabend schön dass Sie
dabei sind Sven Voß hat Fußball für Sie
auch von mir einen schönen guten Abend
und Donald Trump sorgt weltweit für
Schlagzeilen
historische Anklage gegen Donald Trump
als erster exos-präsident muss er wohl
vor Gericht wegen dubiosa
schweigegeldzahlungen an einen Pornostar
zum Spartarif durch Deutschland auch der
Bundesrat gibt grünes Licht für das 49
Euro Ticket es kommt zum ersten Mai
und Abschied mit Hamburger
Hafenrundfahrt der britische König
Charles beendet sein drei tägigen
Deutschland besucht
das hat es noch nie in den USA gegeben
eine Anklage gegen einen ehemaligen
Präsidenten Donald Trump selbst spricht
von politischer Verfolgung Trump bewirbt
sich derzeit erneut um eine
Präsidentschaftskandidatur und darum
geht es in dem Strafverfahren
2016 kurz vor der Präsidentenwahl die
Pornodarstellerin stormy Daniels
behauptet Sex mit Trump gehabt zu haben
jetzt kommt Trumps Anwalt Michael Cohen
ins Spiel er zahlt stormy Daniels
Schweigegeld
130.000 Dollar von seinem Konto das Geld
bekommt davon Trumps Familienfirma der
Trump organisations soweit so legal aber
Jumps Firma deklarierte die Summe
offenbar als Anwaltskosten und das
könnte als Fälschung von
Geschäftsunterlagen und als illegale
Wahlkampffinanzierung angesehen werden
mehr von Claudia Bates
die New Yorker Polizei bereitet sich vor
sie erwartet mögliche Proteste nach der
historischen Entscheidung der
Geschworenen der Grand Jury Ex-Präsident
Trump anzuklagen voraussichtlich am
Dienstag soll Donald Trump in New York
erscheinen seine Fingerabdrücke abgeben
seine Anwälte erwarten dass er keinen
Widerstand leisten wird
wir arbeiten an der Logistik auf keinen
Fall wird er sich in seinem Wohnsitz
Mara Lago verkriechen er wird sich dem
stellen und ich bin sicher dass wir
erfolgreich sein werden
verteidige unsere Bewegung schreibt
Donald Trump auf Social Media und nutzt
die Anklage um Spenden einzutreiben er
inszeniert sich als Opfer politischer
Verfolgung die Republikaner selbst
innerparteiliche Kritiker Stimmen ein
die noch nie dagewesene Anklage eines
früheren Präsidenten wegen
Wahlkampffinanzierung ist ungeheuerlich
naja Anklagen kann man ja jeden selbst
ein schinkenbrötchen
Präsident beiden dagegen will betonen
dass die Justiz unabhängig von der
Regierung ist daher
kein Kommentar zu Trump
auch wegen des Umsturz Versuchs nach der
letzten Präsidentschaftswahl wird noch
gegen Trump ermittelt hier geht es um
schwerwiegendere Vorwürfe
Donald Trump hat seine Anhänger
aufgehetzt er hat mit Tod und Zerstörung
gedroht wenn er jetzt angeklagt wird ich
denke es wäre gefährlicher wenn wir
nicht der Rechtsstaatlichkeit folgen
würden
sie den Florida machen sich seine
Anhänger bereit zu Verteidigung ihres
iOS in unverbrüchlicher Treue
Johannes Hanau in New York was bedeutet
denn die Anklage konkret für Trump
also erstmal gilt für Donald Trump wie
für jeden Angeklagten die
Unschuldsvermutung bis zum beweisen das
Gegenteil sondern um das zu klären da
gibt es ein geregeltes rechtsstaatliches
Verfahren als erstes wir haben es gerade
den Beitrag gehört wird er hier hinten
im Gebäude hinter mir
erkennungsdienstlich behandelt es wird
ein Foto von ihm gemacht er muss
Fingerabdrücke abgeben und dann wird er
einem Richter vorgeführt danach kann er
erstmal wieder nach Hause gehen Anwälte
Staatsanwalt und Richter werden dann das
weitere Verfahren festlegen und da geht
es dann darum welche Jury ausgewählt und
wie die Jury ausgewählt wird das kann
doch Wochen dauern bis es dann überhaupt
zum ersten Verhandlungstag kommt und man
ist hier eigentlich der Überzeugung dass
diese Verhandlung nicht vor Beginn des
us-präsidentschaftswahlkampfs beendet
sein wird darüber hinaus gibt es zwar
weitere Verfahren eins in Georgia und
eines in Washington dieses wieder geht
es um mögliche versucht der Wahl
Manipulation und dann entwenden von
Geheimdokumenten und es könnte sein dass
das Verfahren hier in New York erst der
Auftrag von mehreren Strafverfahren
gegen Donald Trump ist eins ist aber
jetzt schon klar dieses Verfahren hier
in New York damit bringt Donald Trump
seine Anhänger auf Temperatur für
nächsten Dienstag sind hier große
Proteste angesagt worden aber es sind
nicht nur seine engsten Anhänger sondern
eine jüngste Umfrage hier hat gerade
ergeben dass die Mehrheit der Amerikaner
über 60% der Meinung sind dass diese
Verfahren gegen Donald Trump politisch
motiviert sind dankeschön
ein verzwickter Fall nicht nur für
Ex-Präsident Trump und seine zahlreichen
Anwälte wenn Sie mehr wissen wollen
können Sie weitere Hintergründe und
Details in unserer ZDF heute App
nachlesen
im ukrainekrieg gibt es Namen und Orte
die für die Gräuel des Krieges stehen
Butcher ist ein solcher Name
Butcher ist eine kleine Stadt im Norden
des Landes nah der Hauptstadt Kiew für
heute Butcher sagt denkt automatisch an
Massaker an der Zivilbevölkerung heute
vor einem Jahr zogen russische Truppen
aus der besetzten und zerstörten Stadt
ab die Ukraine gedenkte Opfer Anne Brühl
ich liebe Butcher steht in großen
Lettern am Ortseingang es ist der Ort an
dem Präsident selenski an das braune
erinnert und an den Jahrestag der
Befreiung
Butcher ist zu einem Ort geworden an dem
die Welt gesehen hat was russische
Besatzung bedeutet und die Welt hat sich
verändert die Welt ist aufgewacht
als die Russen am 31 März 2022 aus
Butcher abziehen hinterlassen sie
Verwüstung Chaos unermessliches Leid
637 Todesfälle durch die Russen sind
inzwischen von der Staatsanwaltschaft
dokumentiert
was schockiert die haben Leute überall
ermordet draußen im Haus diejenigen die
gefoltert wurden wurden in den
russischen Hauptquartieren erschossen
diese Stadt war mit Leichen gefüllt
hinter der Andreaskirche war das
Massengrab viele Leichen waren hier
verscharrt Männer Frauen Kinder
Andrea Wien ist Priester der Kirche hier
zeigen sie eine Ausstellung mit
Fotografien von damals Bilder die schwer
zu ertragen sind
leider können wir das Böse nicht
erklären wenn wir es erklären dann
rechtfertigen wir es als ob es anders
nicht ginge das Böse hat keinen Sinn an
sich
der Befreiung es fühlt sich für die
Ukraine nicht nach Sieg an
für Finnland ist der Weg in die NATO
frei mit der Türkei hat gestern auch das
letzte Mitgliedsland den Beitritt
zugestimmt das türkische Parlament
folgte der Empfehlung von Präsident
Erdogan der sein Widerstand gegen den
Beitritt aufgegeben hatte bereits
kommende Woche könnte Finnland beim
Treffen der nato-außenministerin und
Minister 31 Mitglied des
Militärbündnisses werden
Deutschland bekommt sein 49 Euro Ticket
auch der Bundesrat hat zugestimmt und
jetzt soll alles ganz schnell gehen wer
möchte kann es ab Montag kaufen ab dem 1
Mai gilt es dann und zwar für alle
Regionalzüge S und U-Bahn Busse und
Straßenbahn das Besondere das Ticket
gibt es nur als monatlich kündbares Abo
und es soll hauptsächlich digital
ausgegeben werden also per
Smartphone-App und Preisnachlässe etwa
für Studierende oder Berufstätige sind
nicht in allen Bundesländern gleich die
Einzelheiten von Dominik
es sind nur ein paar Schritte von der
Haltestelle in die Büros einer
versicherungszentrale in Düsseldorf und
die Versicherung zahlt wie mancher
Arbeitgeber in Deutschland einen
Zuschuss von 20 Euro aufs 49 euro-ticket
und zum einen attraktiv zu sein für
Mitarbeiter und zum anderen den Umstieg
zu erleichtern insgesamt Zahlen daher
dann jetzt mit dem deutschland-ticket
unsere Mitarbeiter nur noch maximal 29
Euro und sind in Deutschland jederzeit
mobil wir machen das in der Hoffnung
dass dadurch noch mehr Mitarbeiter auf
die Bahn umsteigen doch nicht nur für
manche Arbeitnehmer auch für andere
Bevölkerungsgruppen soll es Rabatte
geben und zwar durch die Länder in
Hessen und in Hamburg für Bezieher von
Sozialleistungen im Saarland Bayern
Hamburg und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern für
Azubis Schüler und oder Studierende und
in Mecklenburg darüber hinaus auch für
Senioren doch auch andere Länder denken
über verschiedene Rabatte nach zwar kein
Tarif Dschungel mehr aber dennoch Kritik
weiterhin gibt es einen Flicken Teppich
je nach Region und mit den verschiedenen
Mitnahmeregelungen und das kritisieren
wir ich denke da muss ein Schritt noch
getan werden in Richtung wirklich
einheitliche deutschlandweite Tarife mit
bis zu 6 Millionen neuen Abo Kunden
rechnen die Verkehrsverbände und drängen
nun darauf das genügend Geld fließt für
Netze und Infrastruktur das muss
ausgebaut werden in den Städten und vor
allen Dingen in den ländlichen Raum und
dazu müssen wir mit Bund und Ländern
dringend ins Gespräch kommen damit wir
dort ausbauen können nächste Woche
beginnt der Verkauf die
Verkehrsunternehmen hoffen dass das
Ticket ein Erfolg wird
wie geht es weiter mit Gas und Ölheizung
die Koalition hat sich in dieser Frage
nun auf einen Gesetzentwurf verständigt
im Kern müssen ab 2024 neu eingebaute
Heizungen zu 65% mit erneuerbaren
Energien betrieben werden allerdings
soll es Übergangsfristen Ausnahmen und
ein umfassende Förderung geben 30 Jahre
alte Öl und Gasheizung müssen
ausgetauscht werden davon befreit sein
sollen unter anderem über 80-jährige
Menschen
unter anderem darüber hatten SPD grün
und FDP lange gestritten im
Koalitionsausschuss und was am Ende als
Ergebnis herauskam traf vor allem bei
Klimaschützern auf Kritik mehrere
hundert Unterstützerinnen und
Unterstützer der Umweltbewegung Fridays
for future zogen heute vor das
Verkehrsministerium um gegen den
weiteren Ausbau von Autobahnen zu
protestieren weil es für future
kritisiert außerdem dass die Koalition
das Klimaschutzgesetz verbessern wolle
und dazu haben wir auch ein aktuelles
ZDF Politbarometer und die Zahlen hat
Matthias Horn auf guten Abend Matthias
guten Abend was glauben denn die
Befragten wird die Bundesregierung ihre
Klimaziele erreichen die Zweifel daran
sind jedenfalls weit verbreitet 81
Prozent der Befragten glauben nicht dass
die Bundesregierung ihre Klimaziele
erreicht deutliche Mehrheiten der
Anhänger aller im Bundestag vertretenden
Parteien bezweifeln das
bei konkreten Maßnahmen wie dem Einbau
klimafreundlicherer und teurerer
Heizungen sind aber auch die Bürger
zurückhaltend nur 39 Prozent finden
strengere Auflagen beim Einbau neuer
Heizungen gut eine Mehrheit von 57%
lehnt das ab und das Koalitionsklima wie
wird darauf geblickt na das Verhältnis
von SPD Grünen und FDP wird immer
kritischer gesehen seit Herbst letzten
Jahres sagen immer weniger Menschen dass
das Verhältnis der ampelparteien gut ist
jetzt nur noch
19%. fast drei Viertel finden es eher
schlecht
schauen wir nach aufs Kräfteverhältnis
der Parteien wenn am Sonntag
Bundestagswahl wäre käme die SPD auf 19%
minus 2 CDU CSU 30 Prozent plus 1 grüne
17 - 2
fdp7 plus 2 AFD 15+1 die Linke
unverändert 5%
das würde für schwarz-rot reichen und
knapp auch für Schwarz-Grün nicht aber
für die regierende Ampel Dankeschön
Mathias vorne und das gesamte ZDF
Politbarometer können Sie ihm heute
journal um 22 Uhr sehen zum Arbeitsmarkt
da bremst die mau-konjunktur die übliche
Frühjahrsbelebung die Arbeitslosigkeit
sinkt aber nur leicht im März waren laut
Bundesagentur für Arbeit zwei Millionen
594.000 Menschen ohne Job das sind
26.000 weniger als im Februar die Quote
bleibt unverändert bei
5,7%. im Vergleich zum Vorjahr sind
232.000 Menschen mehr arbeitslos
es soll eine krankenhausreform geben
darüber sind sich
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach und
die ministerpräsidentinnen und
Präsidenten der ostdeutschen
Bundesländer bei ihrem Sondertreffen
heute einig gewesen wie die Reform
aussehen soll darüber gehen die
Vorstellung allerdings auseinander und
so fordern die Länder an den Plänen
beteiligt zu werden sie fürchten dass
Kliniken geschlossen werden Cornelia
schiments hat sich dazu in Sachsen
umgehört
medizinische Grundversorgung für alle
gut erreichbar das bietet das
oberlausitz-klinikum in Bautzen die
geplante krankenhausreform sorgt für
Ärger die Befürchtung Berlin entscheidet
ohne Kenntnis der Lage vor Ort man muss
mit den Menschen vor Ort reden und sagen
was brauchen wir es geht ja nicht um die
Planung von den krankenhausstandort
alleine sondern es geht um
Versorgungssicherheit Erreichbarkeit
Ostsachsen ist über Alter die
Bevölkerung schrumpft niedergelassene
Ärzte gehen in Rente oft ohne Nachfolger
das macht so manchem hier Angst
natürlich macht das Angst oder irgendwas
weil man nie weiß wie es weitergeht oder
irgendwas wenn man zu einem Hautarzt
möchte in ja Wartezeit und da kann es
schon hinten krabbeln und schwarz werden
und du kommst trotzdem nicht dran in
Berlin heute ein Sondertreffen der
ostdeutschen Ministerpräsidenten mit
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
einig war man sich hier lediglich
darüber dass es dringend eine Reform
brauche wir kennen die Diskussion wenn
Abteilungen in Krankenhäusern
geschlossen werden wenn Kliniken
geschlossen werden was das in der
Bevölkerung macht und deswegen braucht
man hier ein sehr sensiblen Umgang mit
diesem Thema
Spekulationen über klinikschließungen
seien aus Sicht des Gesundheitsministers
zu früh zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt kann
niemand überhaupt eine Aussage dazu
machen ist verschwinden Kliniken durch
diese Reform ich kann nur sagen dass
Kliniken verschwinden wenn wir die
Reform nicht machen bis zum Sommer
sollen Eckpunkte des Gesetzes vorliegen
auch beim Namensrecht will die
Bundesregierung etwas ändern
Justizminister Buschmann plant vor allem
bei den Doppelnamen mehr Freiheiten wenn
frau Müller und Herr Peters heiraten und
sich danach Müller Peters oder Peters
Müller nennen dann sollen sie auf dem
Bindestrich verzichten können der
Doppelname würde dann auch an gemeinsame
Kinder weitergegeben
heiraten Frau Meier erkendorf und Herr
Schulze Abel dann können Sie sich für
einen neuen Doppelnamen entscheiden
verschiedene Kombinationen wären möglich
etwa erkendorf Abel oder Schulze Meier
mehr als zwei Namensbestandteile sollen
allerdings nicht erlaubt sein
König Schals der dritte heißt übrigens
mit vollem bürgerlichen Namen Charles
Phillip Arthur George Mont Betten
Windsor zum Ausklang seines
Staatsbesuches in Deutschland kam er
heute gemeinsam mit Ehefrau Camilla nach
Hamburg dort ging das Paar bei wenig
königlichem Wetter auf Tuchfüllung mit
royalen Fans und gedachte der
weltkriegsopfer Martin Niesen fasst den
letzten Tag des Besuches zusammen an
diesem besonderen Ort ist eine
gemeinsame Geste an einem für die
gemeinsame auch leidvolle Geschichte
wichtigen Ort König Charles III und
Bundespräsident Steinmeier legen an St
Nikolai einen Kranz nieder die Kirche
bei Alliierten Luft und griffen im
Zweiten Weltkrieg zerstört ist heute man
mal für die Opfer von Krieg und
Gewaltherrschaft in der Nazizeit
die besondere Beziehung zwischen dem
Vereinigten Königreich und Hamburg zeigt
sich auch vor dem Rathaus im strömenden
Regen warten tausende Menschen und
werden belohnt Charles und Camilla
zeigen sich nahbar ja
und wir sympathisch auf alle Fälle fand
ich Ihnen und auch Camilla
nach dem obligatorischen Balkon Auftritt
im Rathaus und im Eintrag ins Goldene
Buch der Stadt lässt sich der König bei
einer Hafenrundfahrt über eines seiner
Lieblingsthemen informieren
Klimaschutzprojekte während die Königs
Gemahlin eine Schule besucht
mit Blasmusik und Shantys auf einer
Party der britischen Botschaft endet der
Hamburg Besuch des Königspaars nach
gerade einmal viereinhalb Stunden
und wenn Sie alle Stationen des royalen
Besuchs noch mal sehen wollen schauen
Sie in die ZDF Mediathek der Titel König
Schals III in Deutschland und nun kommen
wir zum Sport 26 spieltag in der
Fußball-Bundesliga und ja ein Spiel über
strahlt alles drin oder ja absolut denn
das Duell Bayern gegen Dortmund ist
nicht nur der Kampf um die
Tabellenführung es beantwortet wohl auch
die Frage wer hat die bessere
Ausgangsposition im Endspurt um die
Meisterschaft für den neuen Bayern-Coach
Thomas Tuchel ist es ein ganz besonderes
Spiel
Thomas Tuchel soll liefern
den nötigen motivationskick und das
bayerische überfliegergefühl aber vor
allem den Titel wir spielen eine sehr
positive Energie und wir spüren das alle
Lust haben ich bin natürlich große
Vorfreude auf auf das Spiel sein erstes
Spiel mit den Bayern ist gleich gegen
seinen Ex-Club und der deutsche
Klassiker Bayern Dortmund und der BVB
führt in der Tabelle das schmeckt den
Bayern überhaupt nicht mit nur einem
Zähler zwar aber der nervt richtig die
Statistik spricht jedoch für die Bayern
von den letzten acht Liga spielen in
München hat Dortmund alle verloren der
BVB hat jedoch momentan die Qualität
Tabellenführer zu bleiben wir wissen
noch um unsere Chance und diese Chance
die wollen wir wahrnehmen die
Meisterschaft wird nicht morgen
entschieden es geht jedoch für Dortmund
und den FC Bayern um nichts anderes als
einen Sieg in der Allianz Arena
und die ersten Bilder im Free TV zum
deutschen Classico Bayern gegen Dortmund
gibt es dann morgen im Aktuellen
Sportstudio ab 23 Uhr mit Katrin
müller-hohnstein im Viertelfinale der
Champions League der Frauen stand
gestern die deutsche Torhüterin des FC
Chelsea im Mittelpunkt Ann-Kathrin
Berger parierte gegen Olympique Lyon im
Elfmeterschießen zweimal und sicherte
den Sieg gegen den Titel Verteidiger
ebenfalls im Halbfinale die Frauen des
VfL Wolfsburg
Alexandra Popp trifft in der 20 Minute
zur Wolfsburger Führung
dabei sind die Gäste aus Paris bis dahin
Spiel bestimmt kommen 10 Minuten später
aber nur noch zum Ausgleich durch
top-stürmeren Katja nie die kurz darauf
verletzt vom platzbus Wolfsburg hat nach
der Pause genügend Chancen zum Sieg das
1:1 reicht aber auch fürs weiterkommen
wir haben die Zweikämpfe angenommen wir
haben uns wirklich in jedem Ball
reingeschmissen wir sind unglaublich
stolz dass jetzt im Halbfinale stehen in
drei Wochen kommt Arsenal zum Halbfinale
Hinspiel
ja das war's vom Sport danke schön
bleibt noch das Wetter und das war auch
heute am letzten Tag des
frühlingsmonatsmärz viele Orts so wie
hier düsterer Himmel Sturmböen heftige
Regenschauer im Ortenaukreis in
Baden-Württemberg überhaupt was der
nasseste märz in Deutschland seit mehr
als 20 Jahren auch die Sonne schafft es
nur selten durch die Regenwolken
regnerisch startet morgen auch der April
am Sonntag setzt sich von Norden
häufiger die Sonne durch mehr zum Wetter
hat gleich Katja horneffer das heute
schon mal können Sie in diesem Abend um
22 Uhr sehen mit Anne Gellinek und
Morgen begrüßt Sie hier mit reserien bis
bald
[Musik]
guten Abend Sturmtief Markus ist
herangebraust und hat orkanöl
mitgebracht zum Beispiel auf dem
Feldberg im Schwarzwald gab es eine
orkanböhe mit 154 km pro Stunde kräftige
Schauer und Gewitter sind ja über uns
hinweggezogen und diese kräftigen
Gewitter die lassen jetzt im Laufe der
Nacht mehr und mehr nach was nicht
nachlässt ist der kräftige Regen der
Wind kommt meist noch aus südwestlichen
Richtung und die Temperaturen sinken auf
neuen Grad am Niederrhein und bis drei
Grad an der Ostsee und morgen liegen
dann die Höchsttemperaturen meist
zwischen 7 und 13 Grad anders sieht das
in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und den
Schleswig-Holstein aus da liegen die
Werte nur bei fünf bis sechs Grad das
liegt dort am Wind der dort schon auf
Nordost gedreht hat dafür allerdings
zeigt sich vor allen Dingen am
Nachmittag hin und wieder dort auch mal
die Sonne sonst wird das ein sehr
verregneter Samstag und einzig südlich
der Donau kann sich vielleicht mal ein
Sonnenstrahl zeigen und der Wind weht
meistens noch recht kräftig aus
südwestlichen bis westlichen Richtung am
Sonntag setzt sich dann von Norden immer
weniger die Sonne durch dafür aber kann
es im Erzgebirge und auch am alten Rand
neben den Regenfällen auch Schneeregen
und Schneefälle geben damit wünsche ich
Ihnen einen schönen Abend